not all of the darkest strangest corners
of the universe are in some distant
Galaxy millions of light years away in
fact the most mysterious of these dark
places is right here on Earth a place
with no sunlight crushing pressure and
near freezing temperatures is not the
desolate Wasteland that one might expect
it to be
it is instead populated with a huge
variety of life life that takes shape in
ways that our terrestrial Minds can
barely comprehend
some creatures of the deep have enormous
piercing eyes others have no eyes at all
and others still have eyes inside their
transparent domed heads others glow for
defense or glow for predation and at
these depths where photosynthesis cannot
occur the food chain becomes a little
unpredictable
some creatures typically classified as
filter feeders have even evolved to
become unlikely terrifying carnivores
others become such effective predators
that their mouths are bigger than the
rest of their entire body or have teeth
that pierce the darkness in every
direction
from the Ethereal to the spooky the dark
sea holds a world of adaptations that
jars the imagination and the deeper you
go the creepier it seems to get
what is it exactly about the deep dark
sea that creates some of the wildest
creatures ever discovered and is there a
reason we can't help but find them to be
bone chillingly creepy
the uppermost layer of the deep sea is
the mesopelagic AKA The Twilight Zone
and it extends from 200 meters to a
thousand meters a little bit of light
still penetrates at these depths but not
much the very first color to disappear
is red because it has the longest
wavelength and the least energy of the
visible spectrum
and a lot of creatures that spend time
in the Twilight Zone use this to their
advantage evolving to be shades of red
that render them practically invisible
at these depths
enter the vampire squid catching a
glimpse of it in the lights of a
submersible you might understand why it
got such a ghastly name on top of its
red skin it has enormous eyes that seem
to glow and spine-like protrusions from
its tentacles all give it a far more
fearsome look than the cephalopods of
shallower waters but just as its red
color seems Eerie to us but has a vital
evolutionary purpose so too do its other
Sinister looking features
despite its spooky name vampire squid
are not actually bloodthirsty Hunters
unlike almost all other cephalopods this
creature is a detrivore it gets almost
all of its calories from Marine snow
Marine snow is particulate matter that
trickles down from higher up in the
ocean and is made of decaying
Crustaceans zooplankton larvasion houses
diatoms and fecal matter
the vampire squid has four arm pairs
with finger-like tendrils called Siri
plus two long retractable filaments it
sits practically motionless around
depths of 600 to 900 meters slowly
collecting Marine snow on its
mucous-laden filaments and slurping it
down
scientists were surprised to discover
that Marine snow has a pretty high
nutritional value but the vampire squid
still doesn't have a whole lot of energy
to expend they get by thanks to having a
suppressed metabolism much much lower
than any other cephalopod of a
comparable size
but as you descend deeper the
cephalopods become even more terrifying
the genus magnapina or the big fin squid
are thought to be the deepest occurring
squid genus with sightings as deep as
6212 meters this makes the big fin squid
the only known squid to occupy the hadle
Zone the deepest region of the ocean
their arms and tentacles can be up to
eight meters long and are usually held
at disconcerting right angles the squid
giving itself the appearance of having
elbows and its translucent shimmering
mantle makes the creatures seem
completely otherworldly
little is known about the feeding
behavior of these squids scientists have
speculated that they might use their
long arms by dragging them along the sea
floor and grabbing whatever edible
organisms that they can
alternatively the arms might passively
grab food such as zooplankton or bits of
marine snow
but in an environment without any plant
life to form the base of the food chain
being a detrivore is far from the only
strategy in fact a number of organisms
that are herbivores or filter feeders in
shallower parts of the ocean become
carnivores in the deep sea
that's the case with the predatory
tunicate it belongs to the acidian
family who are also known as sea squirts
a class of colorful stationary filter
feeders that generally live in shallow
water but the predatory tunicate lives
much deeper anywhere from 600 to 1100
meters and perhaps even deeper
these tunicates are perhaps less
terrifying than the big fin squid but
just as strange they look almost like an
eyeless sock puppet with its mouth open
but this odd design has an important
purpose to help them catch prey
as small invertebrates and Crustaceans
swim by they sometimes drift into the
predatory tunicate's open mouth that
mouth quickly snaps shut and the prey is
trapped facing a slow death by digestion
this is also the case with a whole
family of organisms known as carnivorous
sponges they generally start appearing
at 200 meters become fairly common at
four to five hundred meters and remain
dominant all the way down to the hadle
Zone below 6 000 meters
shallow water sponge species are filter
feeders like sea squirts living on
bacteria and phytoplankton they're even
harvested as shower loofahs their porous
bodies being a good mechanism to hold
and form soap bubbles
but you most definitely do not want to
wash yourself with a carnivorous sponge
and that's because they're covered in
tiny Spears and hooks used to passively
trap small swimming creatures the
sponges don't have to do much work
whether it's the harp sponge with its
long rows of spines or the ping pong
tree sponge with its bulbous spheres
these stationary organisms are highly
effective Predators they just wait for
the ocean currents to sweep creatures
into their spines and then they feast
despite this abundance of passive
carnivores there are plenty of hunters
in the deep sea as well
one such startling specimen is the
gulper eel found at depths over 1800
meters in the midnight zone its mouth is
larger than the rest of its entire body
and is Loosely hinged so that it can
swallow animals much larger than itself
its proportions may be off-putting but
in an environment with limited food
being able to gorge on a massive meal
when you have the chance is crucial its
massive mouth can also be used to make
itself look intimidating by ballooning
up to a hilarious degree
but most infamous among the deep sea
Hunters might be the anglerfish most of
which live below 300 meters but some can
be found down to the abyssopelagic Zone
all the way at 6 000 meters
there are hundreds of species that fall
under the catch-all term of anglerfish
which comes from the way they generally
hunt with a lure attached to their heads
to attract prey this is comprised of an
Elysium the modified dorsal spine that
acts as a fishing rod and an eska the
bulbous bioluminescent fishing lure
which gets its glow from symbiotic
bacteria
and by using these lures anglerfish
attract a variety of prey species to
their gaping mouths and they've been
known to consume absurd quantities of
food all at once
researchers once captured a black sea
devil that weighed 8.8 grams but its
stomach held 12.3 grams worth of eels in
other words its stomach alone managed to
hold one and a half times its body
weight in food
to be able to consume whatever they come
across anglerfish have highly flexible
jaws and generally have teeth that point
inward meaning that whenever they trap
their prey there's little chance of the
creature escaping
and just like the gulper eel their
strategy of gorging themselves whenever
they can get a meal is a huge advantage
in an environment where food is scarce
while some creatures use bioluminescence
for predation others use it to disguise
themselves a strategy called counter
illumination the lights on their bellies
helps obscure their outline against the
very faint patches of light coming from
above
but there are some predators who have
found ways to see their prey
camouflaging in this way and perhaps the
most incredible of these is macro Penna
microstoma or the Pacific barilai fish
arguably the craziest looking fish in
the entire ocean
these fish have enormous tubular eyes
that are directed upward allowing them
to see prey swimming overhead and these
eyes are encased inside their head
closed in by a transparent Shield their
vision is so good that they can not only
pick out the Silhouettes of their prey
even if it's using bioluminescence but
also gauge the depth they're swimming at
and therefore their distance from them
but initially scientists were confused
about how it could effectively hunt when
its tiny mouth points in a different
direction than its eyes
they wouldn't be able to keep their eyes
on the prey while moving their mouth to
eat it but the scientists were shocked
to discover that the eyes can roll
forward and see through the front of
their heads as well as the top for a
maximum Arc of 75 degrees for comparison
humans can only move our eyes about 45
degrees at most for us to do what Barrel
I fish do we would essentially be able
to look directly up at our brains
this strange adaptation allows Barrel
life fish to keep their prey in view at
all times even as it snaps its body
vertically to snatch the food swimming
above it but barrel-eye fish live in the
Twilight Zone where there's still a tiny
bit of light available for them to make
use of what about fish that are even
deeper down in the bathy pelagic or even
abyssopelagic all the way down to 6000
meters with no sunlight penetrating
these depths and with little need to
detect bioluminescence some deep sea
creatures forego Vision altogether like
the tripod fish instead of it relying on
sight they balance on the sea floor like
little tripods waiting for other
creatures to swim by
their elongated pelvic fins stretch down
to the ground holding the motionless and
upright while they use their pectoral
fins like hands Reaching Forward these
fins are filled with enlarged spinal
nerves which helps them sense the water
currents and whatever objects might
float their way from small Crustaceans
to fish in this way they're essentially
able to sit tight and wait for food to
come to them even though they can't see
it and while these fish are certainly
deep they are by no means the deepest
ones recently scientists exploring a
marine trench near Japan were stunned to
find a fish living
8336 meters below the surface the
deepest fish anyone has ever found and
is likely to ever find
what they found is a type of hadal
snailfish a translucent scaleless
tadpole-shaped creature little is known
about this ghostly ethereal fish that
thrives in a place named after Hades
itself is this deepest of fish the
creepiest maybe not though it's
certainly not winning any beauty
contests but from the beginning of the
ocean depths just as sunlight disappears
down to the crushing depths of the
deepest trenches there's no denying that
the creatures who live here seem like
characters out of the darkest corners of
our imagination and yet every freaky
adaptation is something crafted by
millions of years of evolution to live
in such an unusual environment
it's not hard to see why deep sea
creatures invoke creepy feelings in us
the creatures are nothing like the ones
we see in our daily lives and without
the Advent of Robotics we would never be
able to see them in their natural
habitat their habitat is so far removed
from us that we liken it to the
underworld and for whatever reason
Humanity subscribes to the archetype
that the sky holds possibilities
euphoric Cloud nines and Heaven itself
whereas The Depths hold fears secrets
and eternal death perhaps this is no
surprise as intelligent air-breathing
mammals that what is bright and known is
safe to us and the unfathomable sea
mysterious dark and otherworldly is not
but our ancestral Consciousness perhaps
never grasped that the world is all
connected that the Bountiful Rivers
ensures that we rely on are directly
linked to the deepest parts of the sea
that what's seems alien is in fact a
vital part of our world and deserves our
consideration care and protection like
any other part of our planet
the evolution of ocean creatures is
undeniably fascinating for all the
freaky and foreign adaptations that
excite our imaginations but some of the
most astonishing adaptations on Earth
happen right here on land and in our own
species human eyesight is one of the
most complex biological processes we
know of but what's even more amazing is
what individuals who have lost their
sight are still able to see human sonar
allows people without sight to see with
sound and other individuals who lost
their sight due to damage to their
visual cortex can still complete
obstacle courses with no knowledge that
they even did so these phenomena are the
subject of the next real science video
which you can watch now two weeks early
on nebula nebula is the streaming
platform made by me and several other
educational YouTube content creators
it's a place where we can take more
risks upload video those early and post
original content that doesn't
necessarily fit on YouTube there are so
many original series like becoming human
which was my passion project about the
incredible story of human evolution or
real engineering's Battle of Britain
which is an engineer's take on one of
the most consequential moments of World
War II the final episode was posted just
the other day nebula has even produced a
feature-length film called night of the
coconut and a genre bending
award-winning play called the prince
which you can watch in its entirety on
nebula and now if you sign up with the
link below subscribers also get access
to classes you can watch dozens of
in-depth classes of creators teaching
you how to create nebula is a gold mine
for fun and educational content with no
ads and coming soon you'll see even more
original projects from us at the real
science team so if you sign up using the
link below you can support this channel
directly and get both nebula and nebula
classes for 40 off the annual plan for
just thirty dollars for the entire year
foreign